you know the standard american diet i
always say has a great accurate acronym
to represent it standard american diet
sad right
hey are you a foodie and you also love
jesus well this episode is for you
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome to led
live thank you so much for watching this
is the show where we use the light of
christ to expose the darkness found in
media and our culture today and today
we're really pleased to have karen and
danica on the show danique actually
volunteered with little light studios a
few years back that's right we're really
happy to have you have you back with us
um
karen before we get into this topic
which i'm really excited about because
it's like um the health and gospel
connection i'd just like you to share
what is it that you do
actually i'm a cooking class instructor
right now but let's put it before that
i'm actually a missionary i'm a medical
missionary and i do cooking class
at the wildwood lifestyle center it's
actually in georgia north georgia kind
of close to chattanooga but i take it i
take this message through cooking and
transitioning to a healthier way of life
all over all over the nation i've done
worldwide programs but
what it is is i've actually studied
nutrition i have a certificate in plant
based nutrition from cornell
university's center for nutritional
studies i've also um
i've also done a culinary program the
ruby international cooking school so i
graduated with that in plant-based
nutrition they had a special program
called forks over knives which many
people have seen the documentary
so since they have i've um i did that so
it kind of specialized what i do and be
able to be more relevant to people who
are looking to go more plant-based so
yeah
and plant the plant-based industry has
come a very long way from like bland and
tasteless to actually delicious
seriously you know it's funny i grew up
a vegetarian and we were actually like a
lacto-ovo vegetarian family so we ate
eggs and we had cheese i was gonna say
yeah
lacto-ovo meaning that we incorporated
dairy products and egg into our diet but
um but it's funny because growing up we
were like the weird family on the block
because we didn't you know like and so
some of the things that uh we would eat
back then
some of these like meat replacements and
things like that were just like odd to
everybody and they really weren't that
good i can tell you that soy milk even
just soy milk has come a long way when i
was a young child they had something
called soya gen and it was like a
powdered mix that they mixed with water
it was the worst tasting thing i i used
to like cry like please don't make me
drink this it was so bad and it was
funny because my husband had the same
experience growing up because uh he had
he's had it before as well and we
laughed because um now there's so many
alternatives you know we have like
plant-based milks and you know and
people have just embraced this realizing
that we have a such a a way to um treat
our bodies so much better and be
healthier and live not only a longer
life but a more quality life fantastic
yeah and zane how are you involved in
this work
yeah so after like how long was it keith
that i was here like two well one year
from the netherlands where i'm from and
then like one year year and a half or so
years two years yeah something like that
so i um helped out around here a lot
and after that um god opened the door
for me to work for wildwood health
institute which is where i'm at now
and i work in the media department and
we started a youtube channel called diy
health and so i'm her camera operator
and um i'm an athlete i run a lot i lap
swim a lot and i'm now going to have my
own show on doi health
called the plant-based athlete
where we'll
experiment with different dishes that
are plant-based but have the right
nutrients for an athlete and so for
example i can be like hey i'm running
this race on sunday morning like a half
marathon what do i eat right and and
normally
yeah exactly and and carb loading how do
you do it like in a plant-based way and
it's still healthy and good for you so
we'll look at the nutrients of that and
then i'm going to
find a recipe online that has that in it
and try it out and even things like
making your own protein powder for
example i think would be really fun so
that's what i do yeah so you mentioned
diy health and we have a cookbook here
on the table um because i was thinking
you mentioned all your different roles
well what does a cookbook have to do
with editing and video and things like
that so if you could explain what is diy
health
yeah so diy health is a youtube channel
where we have different shows so we have
our show that's the same name as this
cookbook plant-based made simple which
is karen's show
where she makes super simple recipes
mostly from a cookbook actually
um
that just help you transition into a
plant-based diet right like because and
you can explain later why plant-based
diet actually matters
um and we have some other shows lined up
like about natural remedies simple
things you can do at home even with this
thing with covid like what can you do at
home to boost your immune system
um and we have a show lined up about
depression and mental health and these
kind of things so diy health stands for
you know things you can do at home
yourself simple remedies um to just be a
healthier person
you actually made a good point before we
get into the gospel side of the things
maybe karen you can answer this
why does plant-based matter
you know if we go back and we look at
our anatomy we can see that we are built
as plant eaters now a lot of times
people all say to me oh but karen we
have canine teeth you know so we should
be eating meat the fact of the matter is
is i always say to them look at a cat
and look at you
do you have teeth like a cat because a
cat tears flesh and rips apart their
food in the wild right we don't do that
we grind our food we our anatomy is
built for fiber you know even
medical studies show that people that
have a plant-based high-fiber diet
have a very little or no instances of
colon cancer yet when people are heavy
meat eaters and are not taking in a lot
of fiber what happens is that stuff gets
kind of stuck in our colon it kind of
putrefies it becomes cancerous
cancer and then they use plants to clean
themselves out like the prune juice
exactly well that's yeah that's true but
that's what they do but if you see if
you see how we we are even just
physiologically set up the fact is is
that
is that we are made for a plant-based
diet and if we go in and i know we're
going to go into more of the gospel type
of part of it but we look at the
original diet that man had man has an
original diet of the the herbs of the
field the fruit of the tree the nuts
these are things that god this is how
god made us now
do we eat meat as a society in a
worldwide thing today yes but there you
know there's kind of reasons why god
allowed that into our diet um and so
we'll talk about that a little bit later
probably so
i thought you're gonna say something i
was i was just i like to get it really
into the fundamentals i mean she said
you know plant-based diet uh guards
against colon cancer and she talked
about you know you you eat a meat based
diet and you know that it putrifies in
your system and i like to go well why
why well that's because we've got
because we've not if we're not if we're
we're focusing on a meat oriented meal
with a you know a think american diet is
a standard american diet i guess maybe
maybe i'm thinking more mechanics why so
okay it doesn't get pushed out how's
that right it doesn't matter okay that's
what you want is that you're looking for
you don't push it out the human body is
is
you know generally 98.6 degrees so if
something is sitting in the human body
it's just the analogy is like well take
that piece of meat leave it out in the
hot sun all day what's going to happen
to it of course
it's going to start to decay and so it
does the same thing in your own system
because it's not moving along and that
creates alcohol which then in turn
causes the colon cancer exactly so
that's really what i was getting at
the scientific point let's get to this
science like why does that i'm so
simplistic
i mean that's the reason i eat a
plant-based dye today it's it's it's
very scientific in my mind i've seen a
lot a huge weight of evidence and i
think there's a lot of
good documentaries out there that people
can view these days too to bolster that
one of the ones i've seen recently was
called um
game changers yes that's that's
in there but yeah i had i mean almost
the entire tennessee titans football
team is on a plant-based diet
there's a reason and
these are big guys you know they're not
lacking in muscle they're not lacking in
energy and they're they've been playing
well
i mean if you look at their their
schedule they've been they've been doing
quite well they don't want a super bowl
in a while but they're still playing at
sure at a high level and able to compete
so obviously their diet isn't impacting
them in a negative way well i'm going to
add something even to that now i'm not a
huge football fan but um oh who was the
who was the quarterback um for the
patriots for all those tom brady tom
brady tom brady is a mostly plant-based
yes yeah so and we're going to say that
many people look at him and say wow and
at his age um and he's probably one of
the oldest quarterbacks that has ever
won a super bowl and has been you know
so if you're looking at that from that
athletic point which i mean you're going
to be doing a whole show on that which
is kind of so cool but looking at that
you're going to see that um
just like it's quality of life longevity
and all of that so in recovery upfront
definitely you know a workout or
something that recovery i understand is
much faster yeah
yeah i mean for me like as an athlete
and as a runner and a lab swimmer like
any time i eat like cheese or something
or eggs i just feel kind of blah like i
feel really heavy in the stomach um
because for a while like i was really
trying to be plant-based i'm not 100
plant-based yet but i'm mostly
uh plant-based and i'm really wanting to
really get there where i can fully be
plant-based um
and for a while i was like you know i
did my research like what do i eat for
on race day right like for a half
marathon or something and i was like oh
you need protein and then people said
boiled eggs so i ate my boiled egg but i
just didn't feel good it didn't sit well
in my stomach
um and then i decided my last race i
decided to cut the egg and just go with
a plant-based protein like i did peanut
butter for example oats with peanut
butter
oats are really good for
a pre
race breakfast because it turns into
energy very quickly and i just felt so
much better it's it just felt less heavy
less bloated so i personally from that
experience have noticed the difference
in when it comes from an athletic point
of view
but hey i want to throw a curveball at
you because you said something earlier
about um because i think people were
asked this question about that in the
bible um you know in a garden eden god
gave them a plant-based diet
but then later on he allowed them to eat
meat after the flood so maybe you can
share something about that well you know
we started out with this plant-based
diet and then actually when sin came
into the picture god actually added in
some other vegetables and things of that
but then let's forward all the way to
the flood now we're talking about like
um
a time period where if you know the
story of you know noah and his family
and that after 120 years of preaching
at the time when god was going to
destroy the earth because it was so evil
he did have that family that was going
to be saved and everybody else was
invited but not everybody nobody
accepted accepted family right but they
go on the ark and now and you know we
always think when you're a kid oh the
animals came in two by two that's only
half true do you want to know because
the animals the clean animals or the
ones that god uh
ordained that they were clean animals
came in at sevens and the others came in
at two right of course that was for
reproduction so they could populate the
earth again with all these animals but
also seven because they were out of
vegetation you think that they're on it
only it rained for 40 days and 40 nights
but they were on that boat way longer
than that because i mean if it's going
to rain straight for 40 days 40 nights
and cover the earth how long is it going
to take for that to all go away and then
we have land mass again right so they're
on this they're on the ark for all that
time
vegetation they're going to run out of
food so there was a point where they
they got allowed for that that was the
first reason i there's another reason
too
longevity of man you know it's sad that
in just a short period of time
god felt like
the earth is so wicked you know and that
i need to destroy it yet of course like
i said we had we had some people that
were still faithful
but the fact is is that
you know when you live to 950 years
which if we think about noah noah lived
to 950 years
how that can if you were a sinful person
how you would your generations would
sinfully populate the earth that god
kind of in his wisdom
allowed meat into the diet which lowered
our longevity you know we went our
mortality rate went from 950 years then
to about 500 years and all the way down
to what the average person lives between
74 and 78 years now
that's about average i mean with a
standard american diet or the diet that
we see today uh it's full of meat and
all that it's yeah well it could be
lower than that too but um so it was
another way that not only because there
was no vegetation and we had they had to
eat but also too it kind of shortened
the lifespan so that we don't continue
to perpetuate sin through our
generations like that well god when he
gives us instructions he doesn't just do
it just because exactly there's a reason
behind it and we're grateful that there
is science to back up the instruction
that he gave but genesis chapter 1 verse
29 is pretty clear and god said talking
to adam and eve behold i have given you
every herb bearing seed which is upon
the face of all the earth so they had
the whole earth
and every tree in the witch is the fruit
of a tree yielding seed to you it shall
be for meat
can we talk about why or what was the
purpose or intention that god gave this
instruction and how it's impacting our
lives today or like
what was what was his um
what's the word i'm looking for ideal
for us and can we still achieve that
after you're saying that we went through
this
age of dedication and our diets changed
can we still achieve his ideal by
following that genesis account
instruction sure well i think you know
we see and going back to what you're
saying about science and how you like
the science of things the fact is is
that when we adhere
to
god's original diet that man's original
diet um
we see that our health improves now i
think that there's a lot of factors that
we can incorporate into that not just
nutrition i think nutrition is a huge
part if you're looking at statistically
speaking when we're talking about
disease and and of course we know that
disease came in after sin i mean so we
understand that you know we're no longer
eating from the tree of life that we
don't all we don't have the garden of
eden around us and and god in mingling
with us like he did however
when disease came in
most disease is lifestyle disease you
know we think of genetics like oh you
know maybe diabetes let's look at
diabetes for a second um my grandmother
was a diabetic my mom was a diabetic
that means i need to be a diabetic and
the answer is that is not true and i'm
talking about type 2 diabetes let's not
you know sometimes we there's some
genetic things maybe with a type 1
diabetic a child born with something to
that nature but type 2 diabetes is a
lifestyle disease
so lifestyle disease just for
clarification in case we have somebody
watching sure in other words it's a
disease that is caused by your lifestyle
that's right it could be prevented and
in many cases reversed exactly if you
change your course of action absolutely
and you know
most disease is life-size disease now we
can have a genetic propensity
so that would trigger our genes would be
susceptible
but our lifestyle and you know there's a
great example is a if you had a gun is a
gun dangerous the answer well
it could be that's right that's kind of
almost like a trick question
out here but um
a gun is not dangerous
if it's sitting on the table isn't it
the gun is only dangerous if it's loaded
right which our jeans load the gun right
however
our lifestyle is like pulling the
trigger
and so that's when it becomes dangerous
and so when people understand that just
because this could be heart diseases in
your family or diabetes or whatever
we're talking about it doesn't
necessarily mean if you adhere to a
healthy lifestyle the problem that we
face is that we're
raised in these
families that you know our habits are
all formed with what you know if you
always did what you always have done
you'll always get what you always have
gotten that's right and so you've
learned these habits so what we need to
do is change our mindset to make better
choices and you know we can start small
that's the that's the important thing we
can start small so but going back to the
nutrition piece of it you know i think
that you know an active lifestyle
exercising you know drinking good water
the new start acronym that's right yeah
and that's a great act e for exercise w
for water and water means drinking good
water we want to keep our bodies mostly
water anyway but it also means using
water too externally we don't need to
necessarily think it has to just be
internally as well you know with things
of that nature hygiene and things like
that then we've got s for sunshine you
know we the vitamin d that we need comes
from the sun right
then we have t temperance and you know
people think temperance oh staying away
from the bad things you know the drugs
the alcohol the things like that but you
know temperance also means moderation
in things that are good for us too we
need to have control of that you know
what i mean in life
a for fresh air right so and then r for
rest
rest is such an important piece of this
you know our body needs time for
recovery and restoration
and if we don't you know uh give
ourselves our body that's seven to eight
hours and you know i always laugh when
people say oh i can sleep on i can live
on four hours of sleep yeah great you
might be able to function i'm not wow
yeah that's right your eyelids are open
kind of yeah but the fact is is that we
we think about
our body needs time
to recover that's right repair and
restore and if you're not giving it that
then you are so susceptible to lifestyle
disease right so and then of course tea
ends it all i think that those first
seven
are so important in our habits of life
but t trusting in a higher power or
trusting in god right and when we trust
in god i think and doing all those other
things it actually gives god permission
to do the miracle in our life i mean
just be being a plant-based vegetarian
doesn't
doesn't exonerate you from every disease
no right and that's that's the thing in
fact the way i understand it um looking
at the data is that people who eat a
plant-based diet they still
die sure of all the same
diseases generally
but they live about 10 years longer with
a better quality of life exactly and
so exactly so we it doesn't doesn't
prevent us doing all of those things
isn't going to prevent us
from dying because nobody has lived
forever right
we can look at that and that would have
been nice yeah but but the fact is is
that we can have a quality of life but
more importantly not even just being
here and functioning i think also being
um clear of mind too
we realized that the things that we're
eating in these processed foods and all
these things that we
we take in
really kind of cloud us and uh give us
you know uh a distorted view and
sometimes you know when we think about
the holy spirit speaking to our heart
if we are so clouded
how are we going to hear that small
voice
you know giving us that direction that
guidance if we're so distracted because
we can't concentrate
so it's just another aspect of looking
at you know healthy nutrition and and
just making you know using health
overall a good health as a part of our
our walk with the lord so something i i
just want to bring out is somewhat
relevant for the times that we live in i
was talking to a pediatrician friend and
she told me
for the first time she was having to
prescribe
vitamin d to children
not even sending their kids outdoors oh
my goodness it's like okay hold on yeah
yes i get you want to keep keep you know
keep your kids safe but you can still
send them out in the yard to play they
still need that vitamin d
you know
you still have to maintain the other
things that are going on so
don't you know don't get so
um i guess throw the baby out with a the
bathwater type thing
where yeah you know you definitely want
to save stay safe during coveted but
it's important to still get your fresh
air and your sunshine and those kind of
things and you know do it as safe as you
can i have um i have three things here
because you said so much important
things but the first was i love how you
said it's about a mindset change
in new start all the things that you
listed it's sort of like maintenance of
this temple and we do so with our cars
with our homes we maintain all these
different things we need to take the
time to maintain our bodies as well
because what's the point to have a
well-maintained house and car but you're
sick inside of it exactly um but i'd
like you to be the second thing is i'd
like you to be a little bit more
specific because
potato chips and oreos are vegan you
know
well this is the interesting thing you
notice i have not referenced the word
vegan okay okay and there's a reason why
you know the cookbook that i wrote is
called plant-based made simple now
growing up you know the the lifestyle
that my family was vegetarian but there
was also the vegan lifestyle and that's
what i think the terminology that most
people
embrace but i look at it in in a
different way because the vegan
lifestyle actually came from you know
the far east religions it starts there
um and going as far back as thinking
into reincarnation you know they think
about you know okay
i believe in reincarnation that if my
mother dies she can come back as a cow
right
so if she comes back as a cow and i end
up with this cow and i eat this cow what
did i just do to my mom
i ate my mom
so
originally a lot of a vegan lifestyle
came from that philosophy that that
tradition
and then of course
animal activism now i'm going to tell
you dinique knows am i like the biggest
animal lover i love animals she's an
animal lover so i both cat that's right
we're moms to cats but we um
uh
you know i love any animal but you're
not marching for peta no exactly and you
know what and the fact and the fact is
is that
the point is is that i there's more to a
plant-based lifestyle now plant-based
lifestyle there's some differences
between a vegan lifestyle
the first is i'll use an easy one honey
vegans don't eat honey
and the reason why is because they feel
like the bees are being exploited right
okay or or abused or whatever that i
don't know the completely but uh that's
their thought process whereas i think i
look at the bible and i say you know
there's so many references to honey
sweeter also than honey in the honeycomb
the land of milk and honey you know
there's a lot of references so
biblically speaking i'm like okay i buy
my honey local locally i do local honey
like i'll go to the farmer's market in
chattanooga you can get honey there but
i also add you know nutritionally
speaking i think it's a better way to go
with like a local raw honey anyway
because you know what you can ask them
what they feed their bees because bees
eat honey
but commercial honey makers are honey
you know pros you know uh providers are
not gonna sell the profit or give the
profits to the bees they're going to
feed the bees sugar water high fructose
corn syrup things of that nature and
believe it or not they get their little
tentacles in that and then they kind of
deposit
the honey in the cell and they're
bringing some of that uh high fructose
corn syrup into that so that's why you
know i like to buy local honey um just
because i also think that somebody who
locally is providing this honey is
probably caring for their little bees
better anyway right so that's one of the
reasons um other also the philosophy
with a vegan lifestyle is nothing animal
product we're talking about leather no
leather belt no weather shoes
you know anything that's been tested on
animals and again like i said i'm not
looking to abuse animals but my focus on
the plant-based lifestyle yeah and you
should add that whole food plant-based
whole foods yes and yeah and whole food
plant-based is really the way that we
should go
the book that i wrote is probably i call
it 95 93
whole food plant-based the reason why is
i do have a couple things in there like
something as simple as adding maybe some
olive oil to something olive oil is not
a whole food and what a whole foods
they've taken the oil away from all of
itself right so because i've added a
couple things in there maybe some tofu
in a couple recipes that i didn't want
to call it whole food plant-based made
simple because then people would say you
that's not all whole foods
it's going to be backlash so i just did
plant-based made simple but it's like a
90 90 plus percent 95 whole food
plant-based cookbook wonderful okay so
plant-based yeah so that's perfect so
you said vegan but anyway so
right no but you answered the question
because you were specific because people
are like wow i'm vegan or plant-based
i'm eating nutrition
right but i still get all these diseases
as a meat eater so what's the point well
think of this this is when you brought i
should really bring it back to what you
originally said oreos potato chips are
vegan okay
yes i i'll say
they're vegan but are they healthy and
that's really where danique brought in
the whole food right right vegans take
animal products out but they don't
necessarily put in healthy foods as a
thing we need to balance our diet our
diet needs to have protein carbohydrates
fats you know healthy though when we
take something out you can take out you
know
um scrambled eggs and put oreos in for
breakfast is not going to fulfill the
body's need you know what i mean so it's
tasty but it's not going to get you
anywhere exactly exactly i would not eat
that before a race
good call
okay so the third thing was you made
mention of the holy spirit's um
communication with us and how depending
on what we put in it might cloud that
connection how about we
segue into the gospel aspect of this
ministry sure
can we before we do that okay let's get
into the physiological like why this is
over here
okay i mean because i think
if you're going to tell people that it's
important to have a reason to back it up
so in my mind it's like well why does
your brain get clouded okay
it's about blood flow and circulation
right and so if there's too much fat in
your blood it's going to slow down the
movement of blood in your system right
and as the blood carries the oxygen it's
slowing the carry of oxygen to your
brain to your tissues to your organs to
everywhere in your body
so
by eating a plant-based diet you're
minimizing that it's like plumbing right
you don't want any clogs in the system
so you're minimizing that so that you
can maximize blood flow right
so i i give you
like a real world
um uh yeah examples so like
cardiovascular disease right so what's
happening what's happening is
you have arteries that your blood goes
through and over time when you eat a
non non-whole food plant-based diet when
you eat the opposite of that you know a
meat-based diet
you start to develop what's called
atherosclerosis okay which is the
hardening of the arteries and you can
think of it like your artery doing this
right it's shrinking why is it shrinking
because internally it's being built up
on the
interior arterial wall
yeah that plaque and it's building up
and so it's it's shrinking the amount of
blood flow that can go through as well
so not only do you have
the extra fat in the blood you have the
shrinking of the arterial wall okay so
you're it's like trying to push now
through your system that's your heart
because it's that pump and it's having
to work extra hard right
you're disrupting the flow of nitrous
oxide through the arterial wall
and that's what keeps your
your arteries for lack of a better term
like supple it's like free-flowing and
able to move and not rigid right so as
you build up that plaque it prevents the
flow of nitrous oxide and so you got
multiple things that start happening are
going on and making it difficult so why
is your brain clouded because you're not
getting any oxygen
right and that's what it's that's what
it's really about you got to get that
oxygen to your brain and the rest of
your body otherwise you're having a hard
time thinking and then you compound the
problem by taking something like an
excedrin right yeah what does excedrin
do well it has caffeine what does
caffeine do it's a vasodilator right so
it's going to open up
that artery
but then when you're off of it because
it's a drug your artery is going to
clamp down on you and say i need more of
that right
so yeah that's the physiology exactly
and i think that the beautiful thing
about all this is i believe it was
aristotle who said let food be their
medicine
is that if you suffer from these
diseases
okay yeah hypocrites if you suffer from
these diseases that with by changing
your lifestyle you can still reverse
most of it so like at uh the place where
we work at wildwood health institute we
have we have three things basically we
have a store a natural food store
um we have a lifestyle center and we
have what's called a center for health
evangelism which is the gospel aspect
we'll go into
where people get training and how to do
use health to reach souls for diseases
but at the lifestyle center people come
and
we have physicians and everything and
they teach them like hey you need to do
this and this and this and this to
reverse your lifestyle so we have people
walking put them on a plant-based diet
drink water get the sunlight
and there's literally people who come
off their medicine by just reversing
their lifestyle
so and people go home and they keep
living that lifestyle and become healthy
people
and when you're healthy let's be honest
you're happy you're miserable when you
can hardly walk because you either have
joint problems or you're overweight or
you're miserable because you just feel
sick and those people become healthy
people so let's talk about some
resources because to some people this
might sound like crazy like what you
mean you're telling me
i can get rid of my type 2 diabetes like
i've had a stroke i've had a heart
attack i've had you know all these
things that you mean to tell me
that i don't have to deal with that
anymore
what's some resources that you've read i
mean i can name some off the top of my
head but do you have any like books that
you would recommend or something so
people can read up on this and just say
you don't want to check that out like
people yeah okay
what's another one um i'm thinking
i'll throw out one pcrm.org that's
physicians committee for responsible
medicine okay um
let's see works overnight's the
documentary
documentary anything by dr neil bernard
yes um
how to reverse and prevent heart disease
by dr derose right now no it's uh
esselstyn
how not to die how not to die yeah okay
i forget that guy's name i haven't read
his book and then there's one about
reversing diabetes i cannot remember
reversing blood pressure and that's why
dr um david david derose yes yeah and i
think he co-authored that with somebody
i know yeah and i would even want to
reference uh dr new nedley's books
because he applies a lot of these
lifestyle principles to mental health
depression and anxiety exactly that even
if you have um some conditions such as
genetic conditions or if you had a bad
childhood growing up that's a that's a
he calls it a
probably calls it but like a trigger
basically
that even then if you apply all these
principles you can reverse your mental
illness so the the genetic
thing just to um give the audience a
little bit more that's one of the things
when i read the china study that really
came out in my mind is
you can use food to turn genes on and
off yeah
they're like switches
and so that becomes huge in your
personal experience you're like what i
can actually
turn the gene off that does x y or z
yeah you can do that because it's been
turned on by your choices so now you can
turn it off by your choices so trying to
study highly recommend that book i would
say it's the most
outside of a a religious book that is
the single most influential book i have
ever read yeah wow do you have any
facilities or institutions where people
can call for support well you know we
were talking about the institution at
wildwood in georgia yeah it is a uh
we'll look at the piece of uh before we
go into the health evangelism piece of
it the lifestyle center itself i happen
to be the cooking class instructor there
at the lifestyle center so i see guests
come and they have an 11 day and a 25
day program but i see in 11 days
somebody coming in with type 2 diabetes
we're talking about sometimes 10 20
years worth of diabetes insulin pumps i
mean not just oral medications not
monitored with diet and exercise but
completely you know right now dependent
on this insulin to balance their life
right
and within
11 days off medications and i mean and
there and they all tell you their
doctors say once a diabetic always a
diabetic physicians you know who don't
study
plant-based nutrition and lifestyle
health lifestyle medicine medicine
lifestyle medicine i should say
um
do not have
the the exposure or the resources to
understand this you know
i know that i i tell the class when i
teach them that you know your physician
most of the time
has had eight hours of nutrition exactly
eight hours of tuition and i validate i
verify this with doctors who come in and
speak you know so i can validate this
and um and then some study more and of
course there are doctors that take this
as a as a you know and hold you know
hold on to it and go and study more and
understand more lifestyle treatment but
the fact is is that you know
they're not educated in this so their
medicine is the way to go and if not
you're a quack now one more question the
same people when they're coming in are
they skeptical about this food that
you're making they're like man this
lady's making some it's probably gonna
taste terrible well this is the thing
and that's pretty funny that you say
that you know uh
the philosophy and why i wrote the
cookbook was to transition people to a
healthier way or life but i have a like
a catchphrase
simple nutritious and delicious
simple meaning simple foods simply
prepared whole food plant-based sure
and easy because i am not complicated
trust me i don't want to be in the
kitchen all day i don't i don't have
time for that my life is busy i'm doing
lots of things and so simply prepared
simple foods nutritious right in the
middle crux of the matter we want
healthy food we want to be putting in
healthy and then delicious
if it's not good simple like i can get
all the ingredients at walmart
almost everything in this cookbook i'm
gonna tell you that if you had to go to
a whole foods once every
four three or four months or you just go
on amazon in the order that's right and
that's me i just go on amazon and buy
there's a couple little things in here
that just enhances the ingredients yes
you know a unique ingredient like
something that when i'm doing um things
that have an egg flavor like black black
salt yeah the colanomic which is an
indian black salt you can't find that in
there it smells tastes like eggs right
it really does right daddy you've had it
but you can get it at trader joe's you
can trader joe's has i got on amazon
yeah amazon you know you can buy it on
amazon you can buy it anywhere like any
of those types of things um a couple
ingredients but for the most part
98 of the ingredients right in the
walmart you know i think that's one of
the biggest barriers for people and that
that's what i'm always like
harping on when i help out with this
kind of stuff is like look
there's already a wall here you're
asking you have to remove barriers for
people to make it easy for them because
they're already resistant to it sure you
know so you have to remove those
barriers otherwise it's going to be too
hard and they're not going to stick with
it and they're just going to go back to
the way they're used to doing things
and that's not going to help them i did
a cooking school
for a uh um a place in florida that was
a very low socioeconomic
you know situation and i really needed
to be conscious about
these people can't afford to just even
sometimes walmart is going to be too
much for them we're talking about very
very poor
i literally bought almost everything in
the dollar store
to change them to a healthier way now
would i tell you that that was the
healthiest way well no we're always room
for growth you know what i mean i like i
really try to uh you know in my own home
use organics when i can't organic foods
when i can and more you know
non-genetically modified things like
that but that's a whole different
subject but to bring people to a
healthier way we have to baby steps you
know nothing is zero to a hundred you
know and and
gonna be
maintained even just meat to a
vegetarian diet is a huge step forward
well that's what i mean and so i did
that whole thing that whole cooking
school and i literally bought almost
everything in the dollar store i mean
not the fresh fruits and vegetables
obviously but but anything coconut milk
you can get there you know himalayan
pink salt i could get there oats i could
get there you know what i mean so there
was things that you could do so
everybody can make a a step toward
healthier yeah it's all about choices
you know i walk into a gas station and i
see a candy rack but i don't know if
you've ever seen there's like bananas
and apples on a racket as well you can
get a bunch for a dollar or you could
buy the stickers bar or whatever exactly
which is probably a dollar fifty so it's
like okay which one do you want to go
with so back to your question wait
before now i have something
more questions another barrier might be
someone might be hesitant about the
qualifications of the people in the
lifestyle center so coming from the
doctor's perspective they may only have
eight hours of health right um health
education but from the
lifestyle educators perspective how much
medical experience do they have and are
they qualified to take in someone who
has a severe disease absolutely you know
we have our providers are physicians
okay who have concentrated outside their
outside their normal training
on lifestyle medicine yeah so they are
now so we so you they're regular doctors
nurse practitioners uh pas uh we have
mental health professionals that are
certified and licensed you know so all
of our providers
are credentialed so they're monitoring
their current medications
exactly it's not about okay you're
coming here we're taking you all off
your medication the goal is to go to a
more natural thing and to and to be off
your medication is going to give you
clarity of mind it's going to give you
you know we know that medication is not
you know there's so many things that are
when it's and it's not you know the fact
of the matter is is medicine does not
make you healthy
no one here can take a medicine a pill a
magic pill or a miracle pill let's call
it i don't like to call magic but
miracle pill that's going to make you
better it may help there and listen i am
i i value
modern medicine because i think there's
a need for it we have to see a doctor
many times for different reasons
but the fact is is that the medicine
itself is not going to fix the problem
yeah we have to we have to we have to
assess what the problem is what is
causing this problem and then we need to
reverse that
uh thought process and re-evaluate and
do things differently you have to go
back to the core because otherwise it's
kind of like you have a wound and you
just slap a band-aid on and you keep
putting a new band-aid on but instead if
you just clean it up and yeah it might
hurt a little bit but then the problem
is gone and that's how this is seen sure
and like karen said like it's not
our positions are not against
conventional medicine it's more like if
we can get you off of it and give you a
healthier better lifestyle that makes
you all happy happier than let's take
that route so i am
going to say something well i can just
add that you know i've seen
you know where
i keep go referencing diabetes only
because i think it's such an epidemic
and i think it's something that is an
easy way to
to really illustrate what we're talking
about um
if somebody becomes a diabetic through
their lifestyle right
they um
the doctor immediately will give them a
pill now the pill will help regulate
their blood sugar but does that pill
ever fix their diabetes no and that's
the thing with medications medications
never fix the problem they may be
life-saving and i'm not going to say
that they're not you know sometimes we
need to if your blood pressure is you
know 210 over 190
you need to take something i mean
putting you on a plant-based diet you
know and and uh is going to take time
and that's not going to be that's not
going to be the answer for the person
that is going to have a stroke in you
know any minute now what we need to do
is address that problem that's where
that's where i believe like our modern
day uh allopathic medicine really it
comes in to where we we could utilize
this but then taking that person and
giving them a lifestyle change
will fix that problem permanently you
know i mean as long as they haven't done
irreversible damage we can sometimes go
so far
sometimes things can't be reversed but
for the most part we can address things
and have that quality of life that we're
talking about on if the average person
isn't born on the verge of having a
stroke it's something that takes time
and it will take time to reverse it so
that's something you should keep in mind
okay absolutely now we can go back to
our question
um how did i pose it the last time uh as
the holy spirit is trying to communicate
with us and what is the what is the
health gospel connection
sure well you know
tanik had mentioned about you know
people nobody wants to hurt nobody wants
to be in pain you don't want to suffer
right
i believe that
jesus if we look at how jesus ministered
to people
he ministered in a way where he went and
met the people didn't he he wasn't
sitting around in people i mean people
were looking for him all the time but he
was always moving he was always trying
he was always meeting the people
and what he did was how he resonated
with him he got to know them he got to
know their needs
they were suffering you know if you look
in the bible there's more accounts
documented of jesus healing than jesus
preaching yeah that's right right so if
we look at that we see here that he was
relieving suffering right because the
world is suffering right so he would get
to know them he would he would meet
their needs
and what would what that would do would
be relieve him from their pain and
suffering and build their confidence in
him knowing that wow i trust this guy he
really cares about me they knew he cared
and then when they knew he cared he was
able to open up and say hey i have a
better way let me show you right yeah so
as a videographer at wildwood um i
for years i did the testimonies of the
guests you know the residential program
the guests came through
and pretty much all of them
what they said that they found was the
biggest blessing is that they had a
closer walk with jesus
because we have a chaplain in the in the
lifestyle center and so they you know
they might be struggling some spiritual
things
and
it's it's really when you take care of
someone's physical needs and someone's
been suffering from some fun something
for their entire life and you show them
look i'm going to do these treatments on
you and they're simple and i want to
teach you how to do it yourself and they
notice the results
they feel loved and cared for and in you
as that person doing that they see jesus
they're like wow and that's when
barriers and walls are broken down
and they can and they can start up the
relationship with god again and that's
why it's so powerful and also especially
if you're if you're in a country where
you know like europe or something i went
to mission trip to iceland uh two years
ago and people there are so
anti-religion they're so like it's so
secular and it's like i don't need this
kind of stuff but let's just say someone
is ill and you take care of that
person's physical needs
all of a sudden you have an opening
wedge for the gospel because they're
like hey tell me more about
you and your faith you know and and all
of those things it's it's it's so
powerful and a lot of times they're
seeing you working i'm sure if you've
experienced this and they're like why
are you so happy right yeah exactly
i'm gonna say that every day graduation
every two weeks it was like after the 11
day program every other wednesday
and i'll go to the graduations because
obviously i've really built
relationships with the guests at the
thing teaching them about cooking and
bringing this home because yeah if
somebody's feeding them there they have
you know we have a diet kitchen who's
preparing these foods but they have to
know that when they go home not only can
this food that they want to continue
this lifestyle because they feel better
everything is better about their life
but they want to incorporate their
family their friends the people they
love
to an understanding of a better way of
life right and they have to also meet
the needs because not everybody's always
on board with change you know and so i
get this relationship with them when i
go there the one thing that i'm going to
tell you that every person says is i've
never been to a place where more people
are so loving so happy
and so friendly so everything like
they've never and you know
prayer is a big part of it we make sure
that we pray with our guests all the
time in everything we do we really let
you know god lead that uh as that uh
part of that
experience for them and it really opens
up the door and i see why this is
important and how it's holistic because
that's that's the moment where the
practice meets the purpose like what are
we doing this for you know and and when
you introduce jesus and that spiritual
lifestyle change uh
package
let me just interrupt wait i interrupt
you but interject one thing before i
forget because that's me i'll forget
the interesting thing is that when you
said holistic
we address the physical
the mental the emotional
and most importantly the spiritual
because you know there's healing in all
four of those you know you may leave and
you you reference the fact that just
because you eat you have a good healthy
lifestyle doesn't mean you're going to
be exempt from disease
it may just give you a quality of life
and a longer life but the fact is is
that not everybody
has a has a miracle in their life where
they're healed physically not everybody
but maybe they're feel healed
emotionally and mentally that's right
but the most important thing i think of
all of this is the spiritual health and
that's what denise said when she
interviewed those guests that every one
of them was like i have a new
relationship with or a renewed new or
renewed relationship with jesus oh
another walk another dimension of this
uh building this relationship and so
you know i think that that really is is
what where is all about the holistic
approach we are we are addressing we had
people come in to lifestyle center a few
years back that were
had alcohol and drug issues you know and
kind of like had been through millions
of rehabs and so i was we were we were
doing a walk one day and i was walking
with the one the wife of you know the
the guy there and uh i said what is
different about here than the rehabs
that you go and that's exactly what she
said
you're addressing everything in our life
you're not just focusing on our drug
dependency our alcohol issues
you're addressing everything and the
difference is getting to the right and
so and that's really why i think we see
such a wonderful you know um
results in the program even in 11 days
you know so i think it just to distill
that down into one thought is that
really the gospel is about restoration
oh yeah right it's about the restoration
of the whole person that's why in the
bible when you read that jesus healed
somebody
um that same word in the greek many
times is the word for salvation
you know in fact i think it's it's used
more so for salvation than it is for
then it uses the term for healing the
word is sozo
and i like how it i like how it reads in
psalm 103 it says bless the lord o my
soul and all that is within me bless his
holy name and you can see how all these
things are connected bless the lord o my
soul and forget not all his benefits who
forgives all your iniquities
who heals
all your diseases
who redeems your life from destruction
who crowns you with loving kindness and
tender mercies
and then what do we get from all of that
who satisfies your mouth with good
things so that your youth is renewed
like the eagles you can really see in
that passage like the entire restoration
of man this is what god came to do
sin destroyed us
and god is here to redeem us and that's
really what living a healthy lifestyle
and helping people live a healthy
lifestyle is all about it's all about
restoring people back into the image of
god yeah especially um back in the image
of what how he made us in the garden of
eden yeah so for someone who likes food
and they all also come to the food again
right who loves jesus and they
understand that we are all called to be
missionaries right we can have our
careers and all of that but we should
always be seeking opportunities to share
the love of jesus christ how can someone
who loves food and also jesus
merge the two
and be a missionary for christ well you
know that i have an interesting story
you know
many years ago i was at a camp meeting
and there was a a um a chef a chef
educator there
his name was julio barilus okay and
julio um
brought a message of health through food
and i took his class because it was like
an afternoon health seminar and i'm like
okay i'll take this right
and i was in
just how he presented not only um
just
being able to use health as an entering
wedge to your community but how he
presented it in just a light-hearted way
and made foods that were delicious and
i'm like wow this is like so interesting
how you could do that
now we fast forward and we were having a
health seminar at our church and i said
you know what we need to do we need to
have some kind of cooking class right so
i was on the team for the evangelism
program right and so i told them i said
i think we after this doctor came uh dr
tim reisenberger came i said we need to
do a health you know
some kind of a cooking class right after
because i really learned about a cycle
of evangelism not just do an event yes
we can we can excite the community but
if we just leave it there right then
what happens well they forget about it
you know we get excited and then we
forget about it we get excited we get
forever so we needed to continue the
momentum if they're excited about what
they're learning about lifestyle
health you know we need to uh do this
cooking class everybody was in agreement
so i said so who's going to do it
if it was like you know you know you're
in the er and then the
machine the heart stops the machine goes
right i was like okay really no and
everybody's really excited pumped up i'm
like we got to do this they're like yeah
who's gonna do it
crickets
after like three times that i was like
okay i'll do it now i had no experience
i had no idea what i was gonna do but i
knew i had a desire and that is what i
believe
god doesn't
call the qualified he qualifies the call
amen called so i said i'll do it i put
together a four night
cooking school
that we were able to do and
we had like 135 people at the the health
program
and i said lord you know i said i don't
i can't handle a lot of people i said
like let's get like 25 people so i made
it a point i said lord i want 25 people
so it was funny because i had um at the
end of the seminar they said you know if
you want to continue learning about
health you know um we're going to do
this cooking school and it was announced
and people came and registered i had 23
people i'm like well lord thank you that
was you know close i'm like okay i think
i can do this right but peop but the
first night
so many people said can i bring a friend
can i bring so i had 27. so i was like
oh lord you over us
you gave me over our idea but it ended
up that it was such a blessing
that i said you know what this is a way
i can minister to my community teaching
them about better health
i think that you know a lot of times
people think that they need to go out
and represent jesus by hitting people
over the head with the bible knocking on
their door and giving them materials and
saying you know this is you need to
change your you know i think that we
need to address where people you know we
have to sympathize with people where
they're at where they're at that's right
you know and i'm not saying that we
can't hand out some materials and that
people's lives could be changed for the
kingdom absolutely you know you can hand
out a little track or whatever and that
could happen
but
that's not how jesus ministered and if
we're looking for true success
we if we call ourselves christians it's
because we are christ-like that means
that we want to be we want to do as
christ did so if we if he ministered in
this way where he met the people and met
their needs and brought them to a better
way built the confidence built that
friendship and then showed them a better
way i think that that's how we can reach
people and i always and i really believe
that when feed people feel better they
are so much more receptive
well go ahead i just kind of think it
goes back to that saying you know people
don't
uh
um how does it go oh yeah i know i don't
know they don't they don't care how much
you know until you know how much you
care exactly and that is true you know
there's a philosophy that a lot of
people embrace and they say you know oh
if a man's hungry
you know
you can give him a fish and he'll eat
once but if you could teach him to fish
right i don't think that that's 100 true
okay and the reason why is because i
think and my husband and i talk about
this all the time and it really was him
who brought this to my attention and i
really agreed you know if somebody's
hungry if any of you are hungry
can you concentrate on the instructions
on things on how to right right yeah the
fact is you're not meeting the need
immediate need we need to do both we
need to
feed that person and then teach them how
to fish so i don't agree with that don't
just give him the fish teach him the
fish i said don't give him the fish but
then teach him to fish and so i think
what we need to do is go out there and
when i do cooking schools there is never
a time that i don't give samples out
yeah and actually i brought samples for
all of you
okay so you guys can go ahead and try
this opinion later yes please um
but i think that we i think people have
to see and that things have to resonate
with you you know you're not going to
make a change if it doesn't you know if
something tastes like cardboard like in
in the food realm
you know nobody's going to eat it it's
going to take about a minute
before yeah there you go it's going to
mess with the trust do i really care god
gave us taste buds he didn't say he
didn't just everything doesn't have to
taste like cardboard right he gave us
taste buds for a reason we want to
desire food but we want a desire and we
can change our taste buds you know the
standard american diet i always say has
a great accurate acronym to represent it
standard american diet is sad right
right but i like to tell people that we
should have a glad yeah and it's god's
living abundant diet and so that's how
we kind of transition into in in you
know really not only enjoying the change
and the journey
but also growing closer to christ
because we're following his well you
gave an example about the cooking school
right but i know myself so i want to
address the introverts who may be
watching this because that's pretty big
but jesus is so like effective and he he
he he did the whole spectrum because he
was in the temple he was in the
community but he also asked zacchaeus to
lunch that's right the person so if you
know someone a friend someone in your
community you can just invite them over
for a meal
and explain to them how you made it
maybe don't tell them even it's
plant-based at first
listen you can make good food you know a
good healthy food tastes good without
even having to address it right
oh sorry go ahead
i was just gonna say to give an example
of that like keith and i go to the same
church and i was really blessed by this
recently um our church does like five
health programs throughout the year for
our community and um the one i help out
with personally is depression anxiety
recovery i'm really passionate about
that and i help out with that um but
there was one i think it was best way
which is uh best way like
w-e-i-g-h but like the better way you
know
they had i guess graduated from the
program and and the people who were
running the program had invited some of
the people to come and share their
testimony about it and one person said
that she actually wanted to start
attending a church now
and it was amazing i was like this
actually works because it's also
friendship evangelism it is a whole
program but you also have an individual
connection with people so i think people
can do it through their own church you
know figure out a program to run like a
cooking school a weight loss program
obviously with our weight loss program
and our
depression exam recovery program and all
this some of these other programs we do
have some physicians involved
to monitor people um
but like my mother she was a missionary
mozambique and now she's a missionary in
tanzania
and she told me stories in mozambique
where it was just people who were sick
they had some kind of uh
some kind of a wound or something and
she knew to do some hydrotherapy which
is
treatments with water literally external
water treatments that helped them heal
those wounds and it was a one-on-one
very intimate connection there that then
opened the door for her to maybe give
bible studies building that choice and
even here united states you know you can
you can pray about this um i'm going to
share this plug here but we do offer
healthy evangelism courses if you go to
healthevangelism.com there's an online
course and there we have courses on our
campus where people can learn about how
to do these kind of things um
massage hydrotherapy
diet all those things that it's such an
intimate and beautiful experience when
you can help someone recover from an
illness like that
and then the person like can you please
give me bible studies
it's it's so powerful beautiful
beautiful i i wanted to add something um
that you were saying that you know like
even like anybody
can find their gift and to be able to
reach people i always use an example
somebody had my husband was teaching a
class about how to outreach people and
the person was saying you know
i have a neighbor that moved in a couple
months ago that has not uh you know i've
not met her i think she does some drugs
i don't know what's going on there
something weird but how do i reach her
so
i had just taught a bread making class
and there's a saying that says there's a
lot of religion in a good location
there's more more religion and a good
life of bread than many people think
so and i always ask people what do you
think that means and this is what my
husband said to to
this woman she said you know yesterday
you made that bread that loaf of bread
with karen she's like yes he goes why
don't you go and knock on the door
introduce yourself and say hey you know
my name is so-and-so um you know i live
across the street and i'm so sorry i
have not been here i know you moved in a
few months ago and i but i made this
loaf of bread and it made me think i'd
like to give it to you and so i hope you
enjoy it
that is a lot of religion in a good way
it is an icebreaker it is the entering
wedge hey it's about friendship you've
just now and maybe she'll say thank you
or no thank you but the fact is is that
it gives that opportunity to break down
that wall of prejudice like oh the
neighbor never came over now all of a
sudden it's like oh well that was nice
she thought about me and it could open
up open up a dialogue to show how much
you care you know and then that's how
that's how we begin
reaching people
well don't just give her the bread and
give it to her in a nice dish and be
like oh yeah and return the dish
whenever you're done
yeah i think people make a lot of
mistakes um with with themselves and
with others when they're trying to go
through this process
um one of them is
they're not patient with themselves you
know they feel like i need to go just
like you said earlier from zero to a
hundred
it's it's little steps at a time you
know i've been
doing this for
15 years now sure and
i didn't start out with like you know
from
at 100 you know you started zero it's
like you're you're taking a few steps at
a time and and taking on what what you
can handle and there's a lot of
experimenting that goes on
and speaking of the experimenting you
know if you invite somebody over for
dinner
and you want them and they're not used
to eating that way
we always tell people like don't ask
them does it taste like
eggs yeah that's right don't ever do
that because you made a plant-based
burger don't ask them if it tastes like
their mcdonald's burgers
asked them
do you like it does it taste good yeah
yeah because if it tastes good
that's all that really matters right
because you liked it and it doesn't
matter if it tastes like eggs so throw
out a little revelation joke for you
uh people will often try at times try to
imitate something you know that's me
that's meat based yeah yeah
with a plant-based version so you tell
people it's not the beast it's the image
of the beast
that's great i always tell people that
same thing i say if you're gonna i
always say does anybody hear like a
veggie burger and you get most of the
people in the class will raise their
hand i'll say does a veggie burger taste
like a hamburger no not one person will
ever say it tastes like i say but does
it taste good yeah and if they say yes
i'll say could you have that veggie
burger instead of a hamburger
occasionally yeah why not yeah and
that's really our mindset that's about
you know changing our thought process
that's right and so you know i agree a
hundred percent if you're tr because
guess what the veggie burger is never
going to be the hamburger it's not a
hamburger it can't be is anything ever
going to be like the exact
no it's a replica it's it's it's a
replacement it's not the same so i agree
100 you can't you can't you know say do
you like it does it taste like you know
beef or whatever that is a bit of a pet
peeve of mine really to be to be um
careful about the language that we use
because if you're like you know i had uh
scrambled eggs for breakfast and then
you hand someone a plate of tofu it's
like you know their mind was getting
ready for the eggs
and it doesn't matter how similar you
can get the tofu to taste like eggs it's
not eggs you know so just yes
being careful with people
my wife and i we used to follow this
chef uh she's a raw food chef named
amber shea
and
she was kind of up and coming she went
to matthew kinney's like 105 degrees
fahrenheit school
and got her certification there
came out with some stellar like raw food
stuff so she was kind of close by to
where we lived and i had her make a
dessert for my wife's birthday and we
met her at like whole foods or something
and
and sat down and chatted with her
she made some changes in her own life
for health she was she was having some
real problems with something
and she went to her doctor the doctor
said you need to start incorporating
these things into your diet
um because you're having trouble with
this area and i think they were
non-plant-based things
and she had a blog and she was posting
about it and people railed on her and
hammered her to the point where she
totally gave up shut down her blog she'd
already come out with a cookbook that
did really well
stopped i think selling it and she just
like
like that community turned on me then
i'm done
so you have to be patient with people
you have to give them
grace
in whatever is going on in their life
and just not real on them like you know
if somebody's starting out don't be down
on them because they're not where you
are
you know give them space and time to
grow
because at the end of the day it's about
it's it's you know talking about being a
medical missionary it's about reaching
them for christ of course not hammering
them on what they're eating or not
eating
and then just to get one more thing in
a tip i always tell people is
an easy thing to start with
dessert
right it's it's usually one of the most
unhealthy parts of our meal that's right
and if you can
tweak that and get give yourself
something healthy instead it's a great
way to start making substitutions
in your diet and making progress towards
more healthy choices
without you know necessarily committing
all the way and saying i don't know
about this you can try it and see if you
like it and it's a great way to
experiment
and improve your health at the same time
i wanted to add to that because nothing
about this is cookie cutter you know
going back to the the verse in genesis
chapter one we have food reference with
cookie cutter yeah that's very clever we
have a variety you know those with the
joint problems actually should stay away
from nightshades in the vegetable uh a
group food group so yeah to definitely
be be careful about how we approach
people and you know not to attack or
anything like that because and every
person physiologically is different you
know what i mean so we have to you know
when people come to me they always have
questions and you know i address them on
an individual basis well i can generally
talk about you know good health and
making these changes but specifically
that's a great point some people have an
allergy to something maybe soy well soy
is a wonderful wonderful plant-based
protein
it's just really it's got so many you
know eight of the nine essential amino
acids you know it's got like it's great
however what if you have a soy allergy
you know i can't just say well don't
just gotta eat it anyway you know of
course we address these things nuts
things you know nightshades there's so
many things that we have to so just
because it's in that realm doesn't mean
it works for everybody and people have
to move toward the goal again we're
always about moving toward the goal if
it's in there if they can do it you know
from my experience the health message
can be such a beautiful thing but i've
also met people like he said
they hit you over the head with it and
they kind of swerve to more extremism
where it is
it becomes pushy and it's like well you
don't do this you don't do this it's
like no no let people be where they're
at and encourage them in a christ-like
way to grow
but
it's not something that
it's not something to attack them with
you know like that's jesus healed people
because like he said he wanted to offer
them salvation
yeah do this and this and this and this
and didn't show them any love that's
right yeah he wasn't like you idiot like
what's wrong with you
i told you
don't you know how to treat your body
that's right yeah yeah well karen i'm
i'm i have to be honest with you i've
been looking at the the picture on your
cookbook here and i've been like
salivating this whole time
but can you tell us where we can access
this book oh actually um we we've just
recently uh put it on amazon prime
so if you were interested in getting the
book um it's plant-based made simple by
karen lynch but my name is spelled
c-a-r-i-n
lynch l-y-n-c-h it's twenty dollars yeah
oh yes amazon prime free shipping free
shipping and looking through this it has
some really good pictures which is one
of my beef with cookbooks is when they
don't have good pictures or no pictures
at all
that is really frustrating and you look
here it looks very simple just like
you're saying it's a cookbook like
90 of my stuff out of because
i you know i like a year and a half ago
or so when i started helping karen
through some of her videos that's when i
i had been trying to transition to a
plant-based diet for years yeah but
that's when i got really serious about
it because it's so simple
it's so easy for me to make stuff and
i'm not saying that because i work at
this place i actually really like it
it's very colorful oh thank you yeah
i i have to really you know give kudos
well first of all glory to god because
this was really a labor of love and a
and a passion to get a message out that
anybody can do this
if you want to make changes and this is
a great you know i like to call this a
transitional cookbook but really it's
more than a transitional cookbook
because we use this at the lifestyle
center so it's it's really therapeutic
as well and we're looking for that so
it's not just like that first step okay
just take this out of your diet it
really but it gives you the option of
having foods that you would be have a
familiarity with or a taste for or all
this you know this on the front cover we
use the um
barbecue jackfruit sandwich with a
citrus cilantro slaw like you know
that's a great like uh you know it's so
colorful yeah yeah like a great uh lunch
uh very american dish yeah like you know
a barbecue you know i'm not from the
south originally but i live here now so
barbecue is a big thing in the south
right so to do things like that and just
find foods that you can love and and
enjoy them but they can also resonate
with you because they have a familiarity
like eating that sandwich at that
barbecue you know what i mean or
whatever so we're going to give one of
these away
to our viewers and that link to enter
that giveaway will be in the description
below just one more question for you
looking at this i
personally
i have a lot of trouble with gluten so
is this a
gluten-free friendly book well yeah it's
very gluten friendly i have about i have
um
a little over 90 recipes in here of
which 85 are either gluten-free or
gluten-free awesome so there's oil-free
there's so much soy sauce
in fact when you when you open up the
recipe
i have a little like um just like a
little they'll say gluten gluten free
soy free nut free oil free so you'll
know right away or maybe they'll say uh
it might say oil free optional because
you might be able to take out the oil
and replace it with nuts or something
like that i give those options awesome
because i knew that there were some
specifics in certain diets like a whole
food plant-based diet really doesn't
want to use too much oil so there is a
way if a lot of soy allergies in the
world nut allergies and then of course
gluten
you know and sensitivity and celiacs and
all that is very very common so because
of that i made sure that i put that in
there to really to really you know
appeal to a good group of people you
know well
okay karen danique thank you so much for
coming on the show for those who may
want to find you or reach out how can
they do so
or watch the show so diy health on
youtube um karen's show is called
plant-based made simple my show is
coming out soon in a couple of weeks um
the plant-based athlete so
be looking out for that
and
on instagram
at wildwood diy health and
healthevangelism.com for the online
course or
wildwoodhealth.com for the lifestyle
center wonderful yep thank you so much
wow so i mean hey this has been a wealth
of information and knowledge and at the
end of the day we just encourage you to
try it you know god's way we know from
his word and experience is the best way
and if we would just allow him just give
him the space to work in our lives uh we
will always be amazed thank you so much
for watching the show please remember to
like and subscribe if you did enjoy the
video and share it to someone who may
benefit from this information and we'll
see you next week on led live
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the dualist who they say can speak
with the spirits the sins will destroy
the commandments forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern for
parents the death note is derived from
the japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
you